هناك شيء واحد يهيمن على
المحادثات هنا وهو
حالة الاقتصاد بينما تواجه العديد من الدول
حول العالم ارتفاعًا في
معدلات التضخم تواجه تركيا أسوأ
تضخم لها منذ أكثر من 20 عامًا
وفقًا للأرقام الحكومية ،
بلغ معدل التضخم
73.5٪ في مايو ، نعم هذا هو  أكثر
من 70 في المائة ويعتقد الكثيرون أنه في
الواقع أعلى بكثير من أن
الناس يكافحون لمواكبة
معدل التضخم المتزايد باستمرار ، فقد
ارتفعت تكلفة كل شيء إلى حد كبير ،
وقد ارتفعت وسائل النقل بأكثر
من 107 في المائة في شهر مايو مقارنةً بـ  في
العام الماضي ،
زاد أثاث السلع المنزلية عن 82 في
المائة ، لكن الشيء الذي أصاب
الكثيرين بشدة هو تكلفة المواد
الغذائية اليومية التي ارتفعت بنسبة
تزيد عن 90 في المائة ،
كما يقول صاحب المطعم ، باريز ، مع ارتفاع
الأسعار عدة مرات في الشهر ،
يمكنهم  لا توجد أسعار ثابتة بعد الآن
ترتفع التكاليف لكنهم لا يستطيعون الاستمرار في رفع
أسعارهم ، يخبرنا
أننا اعتدنا على رؤية بعض العملاء أربعة أعوام  r
خمس مرات في الشهر الآن نراهم مرة
واحدة في الشهر إذا قال على الإطلاق
إنها أزمة اقتصادية يقول
صاحب العمل لقد اعتدنا التحدث عن أشخاص
في روسيا يشترون طماطم واحدة في وقت واحد
الآن هذا هو وضعنا نحن في
نفس
مطعم القوارب  يقول عامل معرض هوت إنه
يكافح من أجل تغطية
نفقاته ويغرق في الديون ، كما لو أننا نعمل من أجل
لا شيء ، فإن عملنا يذهب هباءً
ويخبرنا كل يوم أننا نغرق أقل وأقل ،
كما يقول إن
الحرب في أوكرانيا ترتفع أسعار الطاقة العالمية
في المنطقة  العملة التي
خسرت الليرة التركية حوالي نصف قيمتها
خلال العام الماضي ساهمت جميعها في
هذا الوضع ، لكن العديد من الاقتصاديين يلومون
الكثير من ذلك على
السياسات الاقتصادية غير التقليدية للرئيس أردوغان.
من شأنه أن يرفع تكاليف الاقتراض
ولكن ليس في تركيا ، فإن الرئيس
هو معارض قوي لأسعار الفائدة
التي يصفها بأنها شر
يجعل الأغنياء أكثر ثراءً والفقراء
فقيرًا وقد ضاعف مؤخرًا من
ذلك ، وقال إن تركيا ستستمر
في خفض
أسعار الفائدة ، وهو يعتقد أن
خفض قيمة العملة وانخفاض
أسعار الفائدة سيعزز صادرات وظائف الإنتاج
والسياحة ، لكن الخبراء
شككوا في خطة الرئيس
وحذروا من أنها ستأتي بنتائج عكسية وأن ذلك
إن السكان الأتراك سوف
يستمرون في تحمل وطأة هذه المدينة
الجرمانية في
اسطنبول